hope you all like my costume tonight I'm
dressed as [ __ ] talk-show host
Noah this is you having a good Halloween
so if I am I am yeah yeah yeah I bet six
hundred Milky Way someone's getting paid
by Milky Way I'm excited there was a big
Halloween party at the White House
yesterday did you hear about this some
of the Halloween costumes at the White
House were they were a little over the
top yeah for example Melania Trump went
as happily married woman
I love my husband people getting in the
spirit that's the nice thing everyone
here of course but krispy kreme
locations are giving out free donuts
this Halloween when you come in wearing
a costume yeah yeah it's the perfect way
to kick off the holiday diabetes season
so that's just what we Americans need
right not getting enough doughnuts I was
going on a recent poll came out and it
shows that the approval rating for
President Donald Trump has fallen to a
historic all-time low of 33 percent
historic yeah yeah and response Trump
said you hear that historic I'm in the
history books making it I did it today
is Game six of the World Series
yeah based on previous games this one is
expected to last two full days what did
the world sirs become a hostage
situation
they're like nine hour games now you
want to go to bed I know the other night
I tried so hard to go to bed I couldn't
go to bed it's too much baseball yeah
what too much baseball no I wasn't
saying that oh what you're complaining
about not being able to go to bed no
you're getting nine innings of more
baseball than you can stand that's too
much baseball this one off the rail Andy
is on a Milky Way high right now
he said that's called this is what
happens to Andy when he has too much
nougat spaghetti Halloween Chipotle is
offering a special Halloween promotion
Chipotle did you know that yeah that's
right yeah your mouth gets a treat and
then your colon gets a trick
that's right I went to college all right
[Laughter]
you